[NIKO] Reinforcements!
[FREDDIE] One second!
[NIKO] We don't have one second!
I'm out!
[FREDDIE] Twinsies...
Reloading!
[NIKO] ReeeeeLOADING!
[FREDDIE] I'm out!
*Does that gun has extended magazines?*
Looks like...
I'M out!
[BAD GUY] What are you guys doing?
Ah, shit! I'm out!
N-No! W-w-wait!
[JEMMA] Hey, a little help?
*Click!*
*Oh crap! Is that D?!"
[DANIEL] You ready...
...to get smoked?
[JEMMA] Take me with you.
[DANIEL] Oh, uh, I'm actually the bad guy.
[JEMMA] Whatever, bad boy.
Wooo!
[NIKO] That was amazing!
[FREDDIE] *Sniff*
[NIKO] Dude, are you crying?
[FREDDIE] No...
No, you're crying!
I feel like this year, this video and the other videos we've put out have been some of the best videos we've made on Youtube.
So if you're not subscribed to the Corridor channel,
consider doing so.
And Freddie, thank you for collaborating with us man. It's been like 8 years and we haven't officially collaborated until now!
And look at the magic we made.
Let's do it again!
Thanks for watching!